welcome to this video opponent discards
start with an estonian black and FM can
have a look Yuri krupin scheme playing
for a box with a wise guy in Sweden okay
I'm an ID off maybe try that line I
don't really want to go for main line
like Bishop g5 because i really don't
don't know it likes going forward i know
them poison porn or hear some very sharp
continuation I basically am I would have
booked instantly okay so and I wonder he
yeah Oh normally like it's playing with
g5 here quickly maybe I should try to to
use this fact that he didn't play g5 aha
all this looks weakening really
weakening but maybe if I versus idea
okay but if i can i can just drop bag if
everything else fails what about f5 he
mm-hmm okay right so let's
prepare long castle first yeah yeah I
was thinking Knight f3 Ethan yeah why
not keeping pressure on e5 you how the
house he ever going to castle here this
looks terrible for black he cannot
castle and I'm just very far ahead in
development let's um let's see many good
good ideas now you can take but I like
this one I need to prepare a night 95
move then I don't really want him to be
able to take on a to now 95 sm as the
idea should i do it now yeah let's let's
play that this opens up the center and
make sure that the Queen only 2 s has a
very useful role
yeah 95 but should be five is just an
instant win and I threatened to take
only five I don't really see what he's
doing against that cannot castle age six
is saying besides the fact that also
each five is saying so yeah and now i
can i can just take twice
yeah night XD five you should be five on
de five Bishop b5 maybe you should
should do that about bishops III am not
in that is playable I just thought
castles but bishops III and then yeah
well Quinn d8 it's a very sad move yeah
let's consider is there something better
even now that this is very strong my
skipper should before
yeah it is this very good position but
can I can I really finish them off here
add this one this one is even stronger
we're taking e7 and attacking age six
this is stronger and now it's a double
attack on g5 and the night so t6 yeah
it's enough let's not let's not spend
any additional time to find an even more
winning position um i am rook e8 need to
address route PA this is what i meant
some rookie one and now just d7 Rupert
e6 and the scandal stuff yeah this is
correct item open up brooke d 6 this may
be clean before yeah still I'm still
good
i have c 3 everything else fails yeah
Bishop g5 was my idea
okay let's let's just protect you 7 it's
not like you so got any good reply to
that cannot move any of his pieces and
I'm just taking g5
I can take with them can I can promote
to a night but I don't have I have Auto
promotion set up here let me check
where's this here take some time but
worth it just the rook okay so let's
check now Bishop g5 let's put it back to
always Queen black resigned yeah this
was the trickiest at the end of
switchback too annoyed yeah just an
opening disaster I'm not sure what way
it began I mean it was so critical
really quickly let's um let's have a
look I know that quite often they play
gt5 in this position or in this type of
position maybe am not at this precise in
this precise moment but it's even here
it looks like you're a player will move
it it is supposed to help to control the
d5 square mostly for a night the e5
square you played that so I went oops so
I went for f4 yeah one problem is very
often f is answered by e5 but this is
completely unplayable this is I guess
why I played g62 to cover at five but
this is just very slow i'm going 22 now
preparing long castles and I've got all
pieces in play while is not developed at
all and this this configuration is just
very weak to try to open it up but we
are neither three is a good sensible
move it took me this probably doesn't
help and the compass even
mercilessly wants to play you five and
gives white plus two yeah okay this
isn't bad cannot can't really believe
that this is a bad move i King bee wanna
say is also the common booth and
parrying 95 so this is just just strong
but he has no way to to to hold it I
mean if he takes lettuce even the smooth
soon stronger than recapturing probably
I must admit I probably would have just
recaptured and yeah well this is just
just not very attractive yeah TM you
just lose the house d 6 is also strong
but the combination the pond and this is
still very weak that's too much alright
thanks for watching